bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'audition de thomas fatum le directeur
de la sécurité sociale a été auditionné
la semaine dernière par la mission
commune d'information sénatoriale sur
l'impact sur l'emploi de l'exonération
de charges sociales pour les entreprises
des allègements qui devrait encore
augmenter avec le pacte de à
responsabilité dans le cadre de ce pacte
annoncé par françois hollande lors de
ses voeux la sécurité sociale devrait
être également très impacté puisque ces
baisses de financement ne devrait pas
être compensé
elle devrait être synonyme d'économies
dans notre système de protection sociale
tout de suite donc retour à l'audition
du directeur de la sécurité sociale
c'était la semaine dernière au sila nous
avons donc le plaisir d'accueillir
monsieur thomas fatoma donc directeur de
la sécurité sociale et bien sûr je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
les allégements de cotisations dont la
compensation pour la sécurité sociale
est organisée par les textes ont
accentué la diversification des recettes
de la sécurité sociale et ils ont
également eu pour effet de rendre
progressif le barème des cotisations
sociales ce sont les conséquences de ces
différentes évolutions que nous allons
vous demander de nous exposer monsieur
directeur ainsi que les évolutions qui
sont encore envisageables dans le
financement de la protection sociale
sachant que ça s'inscrit dans le cadre
de notre mission comme vous le savez qui
porte sur l'impact des allègements
ce sur des gothiques des cotisations
sociales sur l'emploi et nous avons à
cet égard bien compris lors de nos
auditions que la recherche d'une
assiette miracle était une quête
difficile et vous pourrez sans doute
nous indiquer quelles sont les
évolutions possibles et quelques
clarifications nous pourrions peut-être
opéré dans le flux des financements
sachant que on s'est aperçu que quelque
part même si on a des standards très
haut
et quelque part une sorte d' affichage
un aspect faciale je dire delà de la
protection et les cotisations sociales
on s'aperçoit qu'on a une somme de
correction qui sont telles que je veux
dire c'est assez difficile de s'y
retrouver
voilà alors une dernière observation
peut être avant de vous laisser la
parole
les nouveaux allègements envisagée dans
le cadre du pacte de responsabilité ne
nous semble pas gagée par de nouvelles
recettes
mais par de moindres dépenses donc
pourrez vous à cet égard de détail et en
particulier les économies sur la gestion
des régimes qui ne semble pas avoir
convaincu la commission européenne par
ailleurs et voilà quelques éléments que
je souhaitais vous enfin des questions
que je souhaitais vous poser pour vous
permettre de nous faire un propos
liminaire et ensuite bien entendu madame
le rapporteur vous soumettra comme il
est d'usagé à la question je ne doute
pas que là un certain nombre de
questions
et puis éventuellement
nos collègues qui sont qui nous ont
rejoints voilà ses directeurs je vous en
prie merci monsieur le président madame
la rapporteure messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai en effet essayé de répondre déjà
certaines de vos questions et de du fil
conducteur qui est qui m'a été adressée
qui reprend un certain nombre d'éléments
vous avez indiquée roh situé en effet un
mouvement général de diversification des
recettes de la sécurité sociale qui
s'est engagé depuis une vingtaine
d'années depuis le début des années 90
finalement sous un triple effet le
premier vous l'avez évoqué la montée en
charge des allégements généraux et leur
mode de financement qui a vu qu'à
progressivement d'ailleurs évolué dans
le temps maintenant stabilisé autour de
l'affectation d'un panier de recettes à
la sécurité sociale principalement
principalement de tva
deuxième facteur de diversification
c'est évidemment la montée en puissance
de la csg considéré en droit français
comme une imposition de toute nature
mais qui a évidemment très fortement
marqué
son empreinte dans la répartition des
financements de la sécurité sociale et
puis 3e troisième axe ce troisième
facteur structurant la montée en
puissance des différentes taxes
comportementale évidemment
principalement le tabac mais aussi
l'alcool et d'autres taxes plus
spécifique qui progressivement
d'ailleurs ont vu leur affectation se
clarifier vers la sécurité sociale et
est en lien finalement avec leurs objets
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on en 1990 près de 90% des des
recettes de la sécurité sociale étaient
représentés par des cotisations
aujourd'hui nous sommes un tout 55%
avec évidemment une situation variable
selon les risques selon les branches à
une branche notamment accidents du
travail maladies professionnelles qui
reste encore très largement financé par
par des cotisations et des nuances entre
entre risques famille vieillesse et
maladie on pourra y revenir si vous le
si vous le souhaitez
cette donc ces allégements généraux sont
aujourd'hui comme je l'évoquais
compenser à la sécurité sociale on a on
est même finalement sorti depuis depuis
2011 d'une logique strict de
compensation à l'euro l'euro et je crois
que c'était une mesure de simplification
souhaitable de pouvoir
d'une certaine manière définitivement
ancré l'affectation de recettes propres
à la sécurité sociale
pour simplifier les relations entre les
financements de l'état et cela ce
qu'elle est et y voir plus clair dans en
effet le tableau parfois compliqué des
ressources de l'état et de la sécurité
sociale comme comme les questions que
que que vous m'avez posé qui figurait il
m'y incite ces évolutions sont aussi à
relier finalement aux prestations et à
l'évolution de leurs de leur conception
dans le temps puisque j'ai évoqué les
trois facteurs qui est finalement marc
la diversification des recettes
évidemment c'est à relier avec
l'évolution des prestations notamment le
mouvement d'universalisation des
prestations maladie auquel on pense
souvent en premier en premier lieu mais
aussi finalement l'harmonisation et
l'universalisation du côté de la branche
famille et puis également la montée en
charge des prestations de solidarité de
la branche vieillesse donc au fur et à
mesure que comme j'ai envie de lire les
livres d histoire j'ai un peu d'être un
petit peu mais emmanuel de protection
sociale nous le rappelle
une claire logique entre un financement
qui progressivement cette diversifié au
delà de la cotisation sociale vers une
prestation qui se sont éloignés d'une
logique professionnelle pour aller vers
une musique universelle donc clairement
on a deux mouvements de fonds qui sont
je crois assez parallèle
dans ce dans ce domaine vous m'avez posé
la question également des dés finalement
des évolutions envisageables est
envisagée évidemment cette question est
au coeur de l'actualité puisque dans le
cadre de la définition du pacte de
responsabilité
les ministres ont l'occasion demain lors
de la commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale de préciser les
contours des mesures contenues dans le
projet de loi de financement de
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale au
travers de donc
de leur déclinaison précises en matière
de recettes ce qui évidemment constitue
une nouvelle étape importante dans
l'évolution du financement de la
protection sociale 3 3 axes majeurs
la réduction l'abattement sur sur la c3s
premier point deuxième point les
allégements complémentaires en matière
de cotisations patronales notamment
l'augmentation des exonérations au
niveau du smic et et la mise en place
d'une exemple d'une diminution des
cotisations famille
jusqu'à 1,6 smic et puis la mise en
place une exonération salariales ciblées
jusqu'à 1,3 smic le contours exacts de
ces mesures ou le comprendrait ce sont à
la fois largement connues puisque
découle de des annonces du premier
ministre dans le cadre de son discours
de politique générale mais leurs
contours très détaillée sera précisée
demain par un par les ministres est
contenue dans le projet de loi de
financement rectificative qui sera
adressé aux caisses de sécurité sociale
demain soir peut-être évoqué le fait que
les répondants ciel à une de vos
questions les conséquences en matière
financière pour notamment les années à
venir puisque ces mesures vont prendre
effet à compter du 1er janvier 2015
seront détaillés logiquement dans les
plf et plfss pour l'année 2015 puisque
la vocation du projet de base
financement rectificatif et du projet de
loi de finances rectificative autres
hâter la fin de mesures en dépenses sur
l'année 2014 et de mesure en recettes
choses évoquées qui ont un effet
permanent dont qu'ils ont leur place en
projet en loi de financement
rectificative l'organisation des
circuits financiers précis qui
organisera
les choses entre l'état laisse que des
social à compter de 2015 sera précisée
dans les lois financière de l'automne ce
qui est en tous les cas actée par le
programme de stabilité transmis à la
commission européenne et qui vous a été
soumis c'est le principe d'une
compensation de ces exonérations au
bénéfice de la sécurité sociale et de la
même façon des mesures seront prises
pour garantir évidemment la pérennité
financière du régime social des
indépendants affectataire principal de
la c3s pour évidemment que ce régime ne
soit pas fragilisé par l'évolution de
cette contribution toujours peut-être
dans le si je me permets de poursuivre
sur le vous m'avez interrogé sur le
financement global en effet
le financement repose également sur des
mesures d'économies importantes qui ont
été elle a aussi annoncé dans le cadre
du de l'ensemble des mesures à hauteur
de 50 milliards d'euros
la sphère sociale contribuera à hauteur
de 21 millions d'euros à cet effort 10
milliards d'euros sur
l'assurance-maladie 11 milliards sur les
autres des prestations sociales
je pourrais tout à fait revenir dans le
détail si vous le si vous le souhaitez
sur ces différents items ça signifie
pour l'assurance maladie ondam à 2 % sur
la période 2015 2017 2,1 en 2001 15 2%
2016 à l'agonie % en 2017 et
donc des mesures d'économies importantes
qui vont se poursuivre au delà de ceux
déjà engagés pour tenir une dame qui a
été fixé en 2014 aura 2 4% pour les
autres champs il ya d'une part des
mesures déjà engagées dans le cadre du
projet de loi de financement pour 2014
et la loi relative aux retraites mais
aussi des mesures complémentaires le gel
exceptionnel pour un an d'un certain
nombre de prestations sociales des
économies complémentaires relatives à la
branche famille des économies d en
matière de gestion des organismes de
sécurité sociale à hauteur de 1,2
milliard d'euros qui
ont notamment se traduire dans le cadre
des conventions d'objectifs et de
gestion que l'état est en train de
négocier avec les principales branches
de la sécurité sociale puisque nous
sommes en train de négocier la
convention d'objectifs édition avec les
branches famille faire avec pendant que
mange vieillesse recouvrement et
l'assurance maladie l'assurance maladie
étant évidemment le l'acteur principal
en matière de coûts de gestion compte
tenu de sa taille et donc c'est ces
efforts vont se retrouver en matière de
maîtrise des dépenses de fonctionnement
et de non remplacement des personnels
dans le cadre de cette noce et
convention d'objectifs et de gestion
pour peut-être terminée ce ce propos ce
propos liminaire juste pointer puisque
c'était évoquez dans votre de votre
guide d'audition si je puis dire le fait
que en tout cas pour la direction de la
sécurité sociale le sujet de la
redistribution le caractère
redistributif des cotisations doit être
largement regarder aussi en regardant
les cotisations certes et les
prestations
notre modèle
de ses côtés social notre modèle de
protection sociale se caractérise à une
diversité de prestations sociales qui
garantissent un niveau élevé de
redistribution les prestations
familiales au premier chef mais si on
regarde dans le détail les passations
maladie contribue également à une
redistribution importante
les travaux de ce point de vue là du
haut conseil aux finances sur le
financement de la protection sociale ont
montrée justement l'intérêt d'avoir une
analyse croisée financement d'un côté
prestations de l'autre pour apprécier la
réalité redistributive de notre de notre
système est de 2,2 monde de mon point de
vue c'est un élément tout à fait central
lorsqu'on réfléchit a finalement
l'analyse de la redistribution divisé du
système on a au travers de la csg un
outil un outil proportionnelle avec une
assiette large et un taux faible qui
finalement permet de financer des
prestations qui elles mêmes sont très
fortement réduit redistributive et c'est
un équilibre
de ce point de vue là qui me semble tout
à fait intéressant de consolider
deuxième élément de réflexion c'est les
évolutions que j'évoquais sur les
cotisations salariales qui finalement
introduisent des éléments de
progressivité
dans les taux de cotisation salariale si
on regarde aujourd'hui en réalité le
système de taux de cotisation salariale
il est globalement négatif puisque
notamment au regard des règles de
plafonnement des cotisations sur les
régimes de base des règles spécifiques
sur le différend niveau de cotisations
sur les régimes complémentaires de
retraite
l'ensemble forme un système qui
globalement dégressif en mettant en
place une exonération de cotisations
salariales jusqu'à 1,3 smic on en
enclencher un mouvement de progressivité
des cotisations salariales qui je crois
est une évolution importante dans le
mode de financement de la protection
sociale
dernier point en jeu
permettra de m'arrêter là sur les
principaux points
parce que c'est important longtemps et
ces critiques perdure d'une certaine
manière
le financement de la sécurité sociale ou
la protection sociale a fait l'objet de
critiques sur des bases de l'importance
de flux croisés entre l'état et la
sécurité sociale et de partage financier
illisible je souhaitais simplement
signalé que les efforts importants de
ces dernières années ont permis de
limiter à leur strict minimum les
recettes partager aujourd'hui entre les
à la sécurité sociale aujourd'hui il n'y
a qu'une recette partagée entre l'état
laisse côté social c'est la tva voilà si
on regarde la longue histoire des
relations financières et à ses côtés
sociale des allers-retours en matière
d'affectation de droits tabac de
différentes taxes taxe sur les salaires
je crois que le la simplification des
flux a été extrêmement de toi et que
cette année mans clarification dans le
pilotage également des des branches de
la sécurité sociale qui me semble
important de souligner il reste
toujours des sujets je ne dis pas que le
sujet est clos mais en tous les cas je
crois que par rapport à des périodes en
effet marqué par une forte instabilité
une forte visibilité je crois que les
dernières années nous ont permis de
progresser dans un paysage qui est
maintenant plus stable voilà je crois
que j'ai dit l'essentiel mais évidemment
je suis à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos interrogations et non
simplement une petite remarque
effectivement sur larmes sur la clarté
du système sur wii sans aucun doute on
peut dire qu'on évolue vers une
affectation plus peut-être plus clair et
même s'ils y compris pour la tva puisque
on peut très bien dire
il ya un pourcentage déterminé qui
arrive
ceci étant ça portait surtout peut-être
sur ce va-et-vient de cotisations
exonérées quoi c'est un petit peu ce
système là qui qui qui pose problème
dans la mesure où finalement on fait
supporter quelque part au travail lui
même c'est une certaine masse de
cotisation et ensuite on la redonne
d'une manière un peu particulière un bon
port aujourd'hui finalement il subsiste
trois types de l'exonération
un certain nombre de dispositifs parce
que antérieure à la loi de 1994 sont
encore mais je pense ont vocation à
rester non compensés à la sécurité
sociale c'est un peu le jeu j'ai envie
dire le reliquat historique
ensuite on à l'affectation de recettes
dédié qui ont visé d'antan à compenser
le poids des allégements généraux qui
vivent leur vie entre guillemets et
encore une fois je sais que les
directeurs de la sécurité sociale ont pu
défendre et continuons je pense à
défendre les recettes de la sécu social
mais encore une fois je me félicite de
ces évolutions qui permet de clarifier
le paysage
il reste par ailleurs ça aux
exonérations ciblées sur un certain
nombre de politiques de l'emploi qui
sont elles font l'objet de dotation
directe du geyser du côté de l'état on
peut sans doute continuer à progresser
dans la voie de la simplification mais
voilà en tenant compte de l'histoire je
considère que le paysage c'est tout de
même beaucoup beaucoup stabilise je mets
à part le sujet d'ailleurs que vous
évoquez peut-être indirectement dans le
questionnaire des sujets des exemptions
d'assiette sur lequel là aussi il ya une
histoire riche qui fait l'objet de
travaux intéressants du haut conseil du
financement l'année dernière et qui sur
lequel on pourra revenir si vous le
souhaitez bien merci donc madame la
rapporteure merci monsieur le président
monsieur directeur c'est ma première
question va prolonger un peu la question
du président j'ai envie de dire
il n'y a jamais eu dans notre pays un
grand débat public sur le financement de
la sécurité sociale chose d'ailleurs que
j'ai toujours appelé de mes voeux lors
de mes nombreuses interventions sur le
sujet lorsque j'étais à la commission
des affaires sociales et on peut dire
aujourd'hui ça se dit d'ailleurs que
finalement sous couvert de politique
d'emploi successives d'exonération basse
et mis en place une réforme implicite
sans le dire de du financement de la
sécurité sociale ce qui à mon avis n'est
peut-être n'est peut-être n'était
peut-être pas la meilleure façon de le
faire si l'on pense je pense qu'on est
nombreux à penser qu' il faut une
réforme du financement de la sécurité
sociale 50 ans ou 60 ans après les bases
qui avait été mis en place à la
libération
alors donc donc on a fait une politique
le financement de la sécurité sociale de
manière par sauts successifs mais dont
l'objectif principal était toujours les
politiques de l'emploi donc pour la
politique de l'emploi
on a réformé donc je viens de dire
implicitement le financement de ces cas
social et si elle en qu'elle serait dès
lors l'intérêt d'une réforme plus
globale qui n'est pas attachée à la
politique de l'emploi
parce que c'est le choix qui a été fait
l'exonération pour une meilleure
politique de l'emploi bon ça notre
rapport dire à notre avis là dessus mais
on peut s'interroger
donc ça c'est ma première question pour
ce qui concerne la nature des
prestations servies
considérez vous que la distinction entre
solidarité assurances qui appellerait
des financements différents est opérante
le savons ça revient toujours au même
sujet que cet effet par sow
successifs faut-il plutôt distingué
alors là
la question faut-il plutôt distingué
entre contributif et non contributifs
troisième question les allégements
cotisations se sont traduits par un
transfert d'assiettes de prélèvement
existe-t-il encore des marges de peau de
votre point de vue sur lattes et sur la
tva et des et dès lors quel autre
assiette serait envisageable
autrement dit quelles seraient
l'assiette miracle alternative aux
cotisations favorables à l'emploi neutre
pour l'économie mais avec un rendement
satisfaisant
quatrième question faut-il accorder aux
cotisations sociales une fonction
redistributive ou en les rendant
progressive mais ça c'est un sujet que
vous avez un peu abordée il ya aussi
pour compléter cette question on peut
aussi et ça a été imaginé dans diverses
propositions d'ailleurs celle de mon
groupe
ne peut-on pas aussi rendre progressive
les cotisations suivant des objectifs
des objectifs
plus précis kifa qui favoriserait plus
facilement une politique de l'emploi ou
une politique de la qualification ou
kiné qui n'utiliseraient pas par exemple
les dix villes et les dividendes avec 7
cette manne nouvelle
ensuite vous semble-t-il possible d'agir
sur le niveau de la dépense sociale ce
qui fait pour partie l'objet du pacte de
responsabilité sans remise en cause
directe de la protection de nos
concitoyens
donc nous avait bien présenté le
programme
mais on s'est pas suffisamment encore
précis pour qu'on puisse voir si il ya
une menace de ce côté ou pas on le verra
certainement plus avec la présentation
du projet de loi de financement mais
voilà c'est ma question quand même pour
juste pour compléter la lanière question
j'avais moi j'ai mon j'ai compris que
vous ne souhaitiez pas dévoiler des
choses qui vont être dévoilés demain ou
après demain mais en revanche vous avez
laissé une ouverture sur les mesures
d'économie elle même notamment branche
famille ou le licou pourriez nous en
dire plus alors l'orage
je rajoute un peu c'était un peu
d'ailleurs le sens de la question de
malam heures à porter secours
voilà j'espère ne pas totalement vous
décevoir mais nous répondre aux
différentes questions que vous m'avez
posé madame la reporter sans m'en tirer
par une pirouette de la conviction et
les mesures en cours de finalisation du
pacte de responsabilité je pourrais vont
dans ce sens là que trouver un mode de
financement de la protection sociale qui
finalement soient compatibles avec la
compétitivité et la création d'emplois
me semble être un objectif
en lui-même c'est à dire que d'une
certaine manière je vous rejoins pour
dire que c'est peut-être poussé par
cette logique d'exonération que on a été
conduit à réfléchir au financement mais
sans vouloir peut-être réécrire
l'histoire il me semble que la question
qui nous est posée au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est comment assurer un financement
stable pérenne capable d'assurer le
financement de nos régimes de protection
sociale en limitant finalement la charge
sur le coût du travail et en
accompagnant des politiques de
compétitivité des entreprises qui ne
dépendent pas évidemment que du facteur
prix d'autres facteurs existent mais sur
lequel évidemment cette ce facteur coût
du travail prix est un élément tout de
même sans doute assez déterminant et
donc voilà je crois que la logique est
bien de diversifier ce financement pour
finalement limiter la charge sur le coût
du travail
deuxième point c'est aussi pour
retrouver aussi peut-être la logique
assurer une contribution la plus large
possible des différents revenus
existence a été le fondement de la
création de la csg je le rappelle qui
tout de même
constitue évidemment aujourd'hui une
ressource centrale dans le financement
de la protection sociale qui me semble
être un prélèvement globalement bien
acceptée par à la fois nos concitoyens
et qui survient ce que je disais tout à
l'heure est à l'évenement finalement à
cette large et à fort rendement qui
permet de financer des prestations
redistributive et je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse courir après les deux objectifs
de façon totalement évidente
vous m'avez posé la question sur
solidarité assurances contributivité
solidarité uno contributivité j'aurais
j'en ai envie de vous répondre de façon
un tout petit peu direct c'est peut-être
un peu brutale vous en parle vrai que au
moins ces débats sont assez largement
dépassé notre système mélange de la
contributivité la contributivité il
mélange de l'assurance et de la
solidarité
qu'est-ce que l'assurance maladie
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une
assurance
oui c'est une assurance quand on
présente on perçoit un revenu de
remplacement comme un impôt pour un
arrêt de travail
non quand elles évidemment est liée à
des prestations universelles et donc je
crois que ce débat il a
je ne sais pas si c'est dans le sens de
votre interrogation mais je pense qu'il
est derrière nous que le débat qui nous
est posée est un débat de finalement
soutenabilité de notre modèle de
protection sociale de pertinence de la
dépense au regard de ses objectifs et
dans une appréhension qui de fait
aujourd'hui il me semble-t-il au travers
d'un large consensus repose sur une
logique assez universel dans ses
prestations
donc je ne crois pas au grand soir d'une
clarification radical qui ferait d'un
côté des systèmes assurantiels pur de
l'autre côté des système purement
solidaire je crois que ça n'est pas une
grille de lecture qui permet
d'appréhender les problématiques
actuelles
voilà vous m'avez posé la question sur
les sur les sur les autres assiettes
l'a7 miracle et c'est comme comme comme
vous l'imaginez je serai ravi de pouvoir
là-dessus faire une percée conceptuel
majeure et sans doute que ça me vaudrait
le prix nobel je ne sais pas mais en
tous les cas sans doute des médailles en
tout cas à l'horizon de notre pays
plus sérieusement le là encore le cap
fixé par le gouvernement est claire sur
le fait que les évolutions de
financement
doivent pas porter sur des transferts de
charges qui ferait par exemple contribué
les ménages à la place des entreprises
là dessus les lignes les lignes de
conduite et les lignes rouges ont été
clairement établie c'est dans ce cadre
ont été construites les mesures du pacte
de responsabilité d'économies sur les 50
milliards
et donc là finalement l'équation qui est
devant nous et à la fois finalement de
faire ce que ces mesures est un impact
en matière de création d'emploi et de
compétitivité
c'est l'objet même du pacs je rappelle
que le principal moteur du financement
de la protection sociale on l'a évoqué
c'est tout de même la masse salariale
que le premier moteur de la masse
salariale c'est la création d'emplois et
que l'enjeu du pacte de responsabilité
et bien de booster la création d'emplois
donc les recettes de la sécurité sociale
comme le prévoit la trajectoire du pacte
de stabilité
et chaque année où chaque demi année où
nous présentons un grand de la sécurité
sociale ou les ministres présente les
comptes de la sécurité sociale
évidemment sont impuissants c'est un
puissant marqueur de l'importance de ce
facteur dans l'équilibré général le
système donc ça c'est évident et le
deuxième point ce sont les efforts en
dépenses que j'ai évoqués et qui doivent
permettre de revenir vers des sentiers
de déficit voire même d' équilibre de la
sécurité sociale à l'horizon 2017
ça mais ça me fait une grande transition
si je peux me permettre avec avec votre
question est celle de monsieur le
président sur les sur les dépenses je
pense j'ai vraiment la conviction que
les efforts qui sont qui sont présentés
dans le cadre du paquet entre guillemets
à 50 milliards d'euros sont des efforts
qui sont compatibles avec notre modèle
de protection sociale j'en prendrais un
seul exemple
enfin jean prendre je suis problème en
pente 2 s'agissant des dépenses
d'assurance maladie
là aussi le gouvernement a rappelé que
les économies qui seront faits seront
faits sans procéder à des remboursements
ou à des changements de partage entre
les régimes de base et les régimes
complémentaires
c'est un point tout à fait central et
donc les 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies que nous avons devant nous
sur la science manie nous allons les
faire sur l'organisation du parcours de
soins sur une meilleure mutualisation du
fonctionnement des systèmes hospitaliers
sur le prix du médicament sur le bon
usage des produits de santé d'ensemble
des éléments sur lequel j'ai la
conviction que nous pouvons atteindre
ces résultats sans dégrader le niveau de
couverture globale du système sait et
c'est encore une fois la ligne qui a été
arrêté par le gouvernement
de la même façon sur la branche famille
j'ai la conviction non pas que les
choses soient faciles mais que les
économies qui sont prévues sur ce
poste-là 800 millions d'euros à
l'horizon 2010 est là au risque de vous
décevoir je ne rentrerai pas dans le
détail de ces économies qui sont
annoncés ultérieurement
je crois que nous pouvons faire c'est
ces économies sans remettre en cause
notre politique familiale qui a qui est
globalement on peut on peut le dire
quand on regarde d'autres pays européens
globalement généreuse mais pour moi
c'est entre guillemets un compliment
justement parce qu efficace nous
consacrons une part importante de notre
pib à cette politique familiale mais en
face nous avons effectivement des
résultats en matière de démographie de
taux d'activité des femmes et on sait
que la moyen terme c'est tout de même un
élément déterminant dans la croissance
économique de notre pays
et que voilà faire des économies qui
permettent de ramener la branche famille
vers vers vers un équilibre pluriannuel
1 c'est une nécessité parce que il n'y a
pas de raison donc la branche famille
soit en déséquilibre et 2 on peut le
faire sans remettre en cause les piliers
de notre politique familiale
je crois que c'est tout à fait faisable
voilà ce que je voulais dire j'espère
que j'ai j'espère que je n'ai pas évoqué
de jauger juste un point commun pour
évoquer que sur les sur les sujets
d'assiette la période récente en tous
les cas 2012-2013 a vu un certain nombre
de mesures de suppression de niches
fiscales et sociales importantes qui ont
permis de d'aller vers la normalisation
d'un certain nombre de d'assiette je
pense notamment à la montée en charge du
forfait social qui est passée de 8 à 20%
et qui certaine manière vient répondre à
cette exemption d'assiette existantes
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
paradigme évidemment différent en
matière de politique de recettes
merci donc je sais pas si nos collègues
ont des observations emprise sur oui
monsieur le directeur vous avez souligné
deux tendances actuelles la
multiplication des exonérations de
cotisations sociales au bénéfice des
employeurs qui sont certes compensée
cependant bon ça peut amener une sous
question c'est à dire ce qu'elles sont
vraiment tout compenser à 100 % celles
annoncées aujourd'hui mais aussi les
précédentes
deuxième tendance et la réduction des
dépenses puisque vous avez juste titre
rappelé le recentrage hammam assez
récent des politiques familiales des
prestations familiales sur certains
publics l'instauration de plafonds le
gel de prestations vous avez rappelé
mais on vous avez aussi parlé d'économie
sur la santé et au delà de ce que vous
avez
dit explicitement il ya aussi forcément
des répercussions sur le niveau d'emploi
par exemple dans le secteur hospitalier
donc si on fait l'addition de ces
mesures de réduction des dépenses se
traduise quand même quelque part sur le
plan macroéconomique par une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages
or vous n'êtes pas sans connaître le la
dernière étude de l'oefe 6e qui met en
évidence ce cercle vicieux de qui fait
que la baisse du pouvoir d'achat la
déflation vers laquelle provoque que
provoquent ces différentes mesures créé
plus de difficultés qu'elle n'en règle
puisque ya moindres rentrées fiscales il
ya moins de rentrées aussi de
cotisations sociales ce qui est quand
même problématique si on sait extrapole
un petit peu dans l'avenir parce que moi
je me base aussi j'ai toujours ça en
tête j'ai lu je pense que c'est ce que
j'ai lu est vrai que le haut conseil
pour l'assurance maladie pour l'avenir
l'assurance maladie à chiffrer un petit
peu les besoins fil de l'eau pour
l'assurance maladie on arrive à des
sommes quand même qu'ils sont
extraordinaires 46 milliards je crois à
trouver en 2060 pour financer un niveau
égal le laquelle les caisses d'assurance
maladie
bon donc je voudrais savoir si ce que
vous travaillez aussi sur d'autres
solutions parce que on voit bien là
l'impasse vers laquelle on peut aller
tout ça se fera peut-être
progressivement en tout cas on voit bien
qu'on peut aller vers une impasse ce que
vous travaillez sur d'autres solutions
notamment sur d'autres recettes pour
alimenter notre système de sécurité
sociale je pense aux recettes qu'on
pourrait trouver du côté des revenus
financiers des entreprises puisqu'on
sait que elles sont le double à peu près
de ce que
cotisent les entreprises sinon je crois
que l'on va vers une espèce de déprime
générale et je souhaiterais quand même
attirer l'attention de sur l'intitulé
notre mission qui est quand même de
faire le lien entre ces exonérations de
cotisations sociales et l'emploi or il
me semble que si vous effectivement vous
dégager des économies à parentaux vous
essayez de de soulager la trésorerie des
entreprises à terme d'un point de vue
macroéconomique toutes ces politiques ne
peuvent conduire qu'à une aggravation
selon moi de la situation dont je
voulais savoir si vous travaillez sur
d'autres pistes
oui en même temps que vous allez pouvoir
répondre aux questions dans notre
collègue sénateur watrin peut-être
puis-je rajouter une question qui est ok
corral et peut-être aux mesures aussi
d'économie ont évoqué tout à l'heure
donc le gel des prestations qui
incarnait une pendant un certain temps
mais comment de manière pérenne c'est
sap est une ressource quoi je dirai ce
que c'est l'acquisition d'habitude ou je
ne sais pas je pose la question
à ce stade pour répondre monsieur
sénateurs à votre interrogation nous
sommes concentrés sur la mise en oeuvre
des mesures qui ont été annoncées donc
pas véritablement dans la construction
de mesures alternatives signaler tout de
même que
d'une part la mesure sur les
exonérations salariales que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
représente une augmentation du salaire
net au smic de près de 520 euros sur une
année ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
négligeable matière d'augmentation du
salaire net c'est l'effet de cette pro
de progressivité des cotisations
salariales que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
par ailleurs sur le sujet plus
spécifique du pouvoir d'achat des
mesures de l'évolution fiscale ont été
également annoncées à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros sur 2014 qui
concerneront les foyers les plus
modestes et donc je crois qu'ils sont
assez significatives sur ce terrain là
s'agissant du s'agissant de l'effet
finalement déflationniste entre
guillemets que vous évoquez ou qui
pourraient déprimer la croissance des
mesures d'économies il me semble tout de
même que
le fait de tenir nos dépenses
d'assurance-maladie de baisser par
exemple les prix des médicaments
participent finalement de mesures qui ne
sont pas défavorables au pouvoir d'achat
pourrait même évoqué d'ailleurs au
travers d'une modération des dépenses
d'assurance maladie sans transfert vers
les organismes complémentaires
une modération automatique qui doit se
faire logiquement sur les cotisations
des organismes complémentaires puisque
partir du moment où vous ne transférer
pas dépenses vers les organismes
complémentaires mais vous maîtrisez
globalement la dépense de santé ça veut
dire que vous contribuez à une
modération des cotisations des
organismes complémentaires santé donc ce
n'est pas tout à fait neutre non plus en
termes de pouvoir d'achat
s'agissant des projections vous avez
évoqué sur le du haut conseil pour
l'avenir de l'assurance maladie ces
projections elles sont finalement entre
guillemets si on ne fait rien au fil de
l'eau ces projections sont intéressantes
mais en réalité oui si nous laissons
filer les dépenses d'assurance maladie
sans rien faire si nous ne promouvons
pas générique
si nous n'agissons pas sur la bonne les
bonnes pratiques l'organisation des
systèmes al aroui les dépenses vont plus
vite
comme dans tous les pays du monde que la
richesse nationale voilà grosso modo ça
va à peu près 1 4%
donc si on a une croissance à 2%
d'ailleurs on peut dire si on a deux
pour cent par an de croissance en volume
est à peu près 4 % en valeur on y arrive
mais sur longue période c'est difficile
mais tout l'objectif c'est justement de
ne pas rester inactif et et nous savons
qu'il ya dans le système des gisements
d'efficience dans l'organisation qui je
crois sont tout à fait atteignable de
vue ville en tous les cas 2012
nous tenons nos objectifs de dépenses
d'assurance maladie sans opérer
transfert vers les organismes
complémentaires et je crois que nous
pouvons continuer dans cette voie
s'agissant des prélèvements sur le
capital
comme je les ai vécus tout à l'heure des
différentes augmentations ont été mises
en place depuis 2012
on a aujourd'hui un prélèvement social
sur le capital qui est à 15 5% et qui
est tout de même un niveau non
totalement négligeable
s'agissant du gel
tout en n'étant pas totalement certain
d'avoir bien appréhender votre question
monsieur le président vous on excusera
nous sommes bien dans une mesure
exceptionnelle ne gèle je crois que ça a
été clairement indiquée par ya deux ans
de recherches d'istres il n'y a pas de
recherche pérenne quoi donc c'est un gel
momentané
voilà le montant d'économies
sur les gels représente au global
à l'horizon 2017 1 2 milliard d'euros
oui c'est à dire on gèle et ensuite
l'économie si vous me permettez cette
technique vieilli entre guillemets
puisque elle a un effet sur la
révolution de dépenses non prévues pour
une année c'est pour une année c'est
pour une année 1,2 milliard à l'horizon
2017 sur la baisse des coûts des
médicaments où on va donc source
d'économies tout le monde adhère à ça et
je l'espère surtout au regard de ce que
les bons résultats de l'est que deux des
industries pharmaceutiques
on se dit un peu de marge mais ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'on cherche à
économiser sur ce poste
j'aimerais bien savoir les expériences
antérieures
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont donné comme
résultats effectifs d'économies les
baisses du prix des médicaments
notre collègue monsieur deligny donc sur
merci ma précédente
peut-être que le président parle emporte
toujours prendre la parole pour une
autre question ensuite mais sur ce sujet
des médicaments donc sur les dernières
années depuis des mesures qui remonte à
la ministre roselyne bachelot en passant
par xavier bertrand jusqu'à aujourd'hui
marisol touraine on peut estimer les
réductions de dépenses en matière de
médicaments alors l'industrie 10 5
milliards causerait après trois
milliards de mesures directes de baisse
de prix mais où un peu plus et puis 2
milliards ou un peu moins de
conséquences pour les laboratoires
d'autres mesures vont par exemple moins
de consommation
c'est pas une baisse de prix mais c'est
moins de recettes dans les 10 milliards
qui sont envisagées de recettes pour
l'assurance maladie
alors est ce que je me trompe et c'est
pas loin de la moitié ou la moitié 50%
dans le nouveau 5 milliards pour le
médicament alors est ce que ces
mesures-là sont aujourd'hui compatibles
sur la durée avec le maintien de
l'activité économique pharmaceutique en
france qui est une activité qui
contribue au fait dire bon équilibre qui
appuie sur le bon plateau de la balance
commerciale française
ça c'est le premier élément est une
industrie qui comporte également des
secteurs de recherche importants or nous
savons qu'aujourd'hui des laboratoires
cherche à implanter des centres de
recherche hésite entre l'italie la
france la grande bretagne d'autres
continents est-ce que nous mesurons
l'impact sur la présence actuelle et la
présence future de l'industrie
pharmaceutique des mesures qui ont déjà
été prises en manière de réduction des
médicaments et de celles qui sont
envisagées
monsieur le directeur je vous en prie
alors pour ce qui me concerne je n'ai
pas de doute y deux mesures
de cette présence
de l'industrie pharmaceutique en france
cela ne relève pas directement de mon
champ de compétence néanmoins néanmoins
ce que je peux souligner c'est que ces
baisses de prix et ses actions sur les
prescriptions et les volumes se sont
fait depuis maintenant plusieurs années
tout en respectant le cadre ce qu'on
appelle le cadre conventionnel entre le
gouvernement et et des industriels au
travers de l'accord cadre qui lit le
communiqué nomi des produits de santé et
les représentants de l'industrie du
médicament se sont fait également
parallèlement aux la tenue du conseil
stratégique des industries de santé des
comités de filière de l'industrie
pharmaceutique donc je crois que notre
politique du médicament elle repose bien
sur deux sur ses deux jambes d'un côté
c'est vrai des politiques de régulation
de l'autre des politiques qui valorise
l'innovation et le volet industriel
j'ai pour ma part la conviction que nous
pouvons faire et poursuivre des
politiques de baisses de prix dans le
cadre de ce dialogue conventionnelle
avec l'industrie pour payer la justine
ovation mais justement payer la vraie
innovation différents travaux de
l'assurance maladie montre que par
exemple sur le prédisent une eric nous
pouvons poursuivre des baisses
raisonnable
voilà je crois que ces économies sont
exigeantes mais compatible avec la
préservation d'un tissu industriel en
rappelant que notre dépenses de
médicaments par habitant reste parmi les
plus élevés en europe certes l'écart
s'est réduit ces dernières années par
rapport aux autres pays mais de mémoire
je crois que nous sommes le quatrième
pays le cdo en dépenses de médicaments
par habitant ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait neutre tant mieux entre guillemets
dans l'axé par ce que ça veut dire aussi
qu'on a un accès rapide à des
traitements coûteux mais on sait aussi
que dans notre pays on a en effet un
accès extrêmement rapide
ce que les spécialistes appellent
l'effet structurale et traitement
toujours les plus les plus coûteux dans
des niveaux et un rythme qui parfois
peut nous interroger
donc je crois que la ministre l'a
évoquée
ajustement des prix du médicament
développement du médicament générique
promotion des bonnes pratiques
c'est en effet un des leviers des 10
milliards d'euros ce n'est pas ça n'est
pas le seul l'ensemble finalement deux
des segments de l'offre de soins seront
concernés par les par les efforts et
sont déjà concernés par des efforts
importants qui sont faits la communauté
hospitalière également prendre la partie
prend sa part pardon dans cet effort là
de même que que les professions
libérales donc voilà il est sûr que ce
le challenge je dirai au moins tu au fur
et à mesure connaît le quantum
d'économies augmente mais les
indicateurs globaux laisse à penser que
c'est tout à fait faisable 5 milliards
déjà envisagés
non je ne confirme pas parce que ce que
ce que je peux confirmer c'est que
comme la ministre a indiqué un effort de
3,5 milliards d'euros concernera les
prix du médicament et la promotion des
médicaments génériques est ce qui a déjà
été réalisé ce qui a été généralisé le
l'ordre gore l'heure de vous que vous
indiquez me semble cohérent mais il
faudrait quand même regarder quelle est
la période de référence mais un ordre de
grandeur qui n'est pas là donc c'est de
l'ordre de 5 milliards tout compris
effets directs et indirects
et là vous vous dites 3 milliards et
demi un peu fort envisager
éventuellement avec toute la prudence
possible qu'on veut donner à ces chiens
d'accord une fois derrière les trois
milliards et demi il y à des actions en
matière de baisse de prix et pour
monsieur numérique la manche neige et
avait comme une politique de
déremboursement qui était important que
l est pas c'est parce qu'on annonce
question c'est s agit-il pour vous d'un
effort considérable ou où est ce que
c'est un effort supportable je crois que
c'est si vous me permettez monsieur le
président c'est un qualificatif
éminemment subjectif selon que l'on se
situe dans le bureau du directeur de la
sécurité sociale ou dans celui de des
industries de santé
je considère que c'est un effort
important mais compatible avec encore
une fois l'accès à l'innovation je
signale d'ailleurs que nous avons devant
nous des innovations majeures a
d'ailleurs acquis sont pas devant nous
qui sont chez nous aujourd'hui en
matière de traitement médicamenteux
je pense ce traitement de l'hépatite c
qui sont une excellente nouvelle en
matière de santé publique puisque
rassemblement est sous le contrôle des
autorités médicales plus experte que moi
ces nouveaux traitements sont
extrêmement prometteurs en matière de
traitement l'hépatite c mais qui vont
représenter des coûts par patient
important et donc une charge importante
pour les prochaines années pour
l'assurance maladie
donc
tout l'enjeu c'est de capable de faire
des efforts d'efficience dans le système
pour pouvoir justement prendre en charge
ces nouveaux traitements est bien
évident que nous les remboursons en
france mais voilà le paysage il est
aussi celui là d'un des jeunes et même
des en ce moment puisque ces médicaments
là ont eu là et même en début d'année
son temps son appel ont été vus à
l'autorisation de traitement d'urgence
et est donc voila tu signé une dernière
question alors peut-être principal de
questions c'est une sur la tva est ce
que l'on a
idée mais je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
dit que ça m'a échappé la part que
représente la tva aujourd'hui dans
l'ensemble du financement de la sécurité
sociale est ce que cette part est
significative toujours sur la tva
lorsque ministère des finances indique
que les compensations relèveront de
tuyauterie c'est le langage utilisé est
ce que au bout d'un tuyau c'est toujours
de la tva ou ce que ça peut être une
autre recette que la tva est sur la même
question pour sourire un peu mais
lorsque la tva contribuer au financement
de la sécu et sociale est ce que ce
n'est pas tout simplement la tva sociale
telle qu'elle avait fait l'objet de
débats dans ce pays
et puis il ya une autre question en
liaison avec un article des échos que
j'espère avoir lu correctement
donc les économies mais c'est pas vrai
seulement pour la suisse de social c'est
vrai pour les finances publiques et
c'était vrai de tous temps sont toujours
calculée par rapport à une trajectoire
comme vous l'avez dire bien indiquer
d'où leur trajectoire qui se déroulerait
si on ne faisait rien ce qui fait que
c'est quelquefois surprenant pour le
commun des mortels on peut réaliser des
économies et dépenser plus c'est comme
ça en finance ce public alors qu'elle la
question c'est quelle est la fiabilité
des trajectoires supposé puisqu'il
semblerait à la lecture des résultats
mais pas spécialement des résultats de
finances sociales mais des finances
publiques que les trajectoires aurait pu
être insuffisamment évaluer avec
précision jeudi cette précaution
insuffisamment évolué avec précaution et
donc évidemment les économies elle-même
ne sont plus tout à fait réaliser si la
trajectoire était pas bien calculé
la question est prudente à une réponse
prudente aussi pourra pourra l'être on
exemple coefficient d'élasticité si
j'ose dire la bouche mais néanmoins
saluant la tva le la tva représente je
représentais en 2013 8,8 milliards
d'euros dans les recettes de la sécurité
sociale
et sans vouloir la non plus refaire une
pirouette l'attribution de tva la
sécurité sociale est bien antérieure à
des tentatives de réformes récentes
autour de la tva sociale puisque alors
avant d'être de la tva nette c'était la
tva sectorielle sur un certain nombre de
produits de producteurs sur le tabac les
produits pharmaceutiques et la tva santé
mais pour le l'année si on regarde
l'année 2011
on avait déjà un peu moins de 8
milliards d'euros de tva qui était
affecté à la c4 sociale dense comme ce
que je disais c'est à dire que dans le
panier de recettes
il ya toujours eu c'est un peu rapide
mais il ya déjà depuis quelques années
de la tva qui est affecté s'agissant de
des tuyaux que vous avez évoquées je
n'ai à ce stade de l'année il est trop
tôt pour répondre à cette à cette
interrogation est donc ces sujets seront
revus dans le cadre de la loi de
finances et lois de financement pour
2015 sur la fiabilité des trajectoires
peut-être votre question a peut-être un
lien sans doute d'ailleurs avec
finalement le la source des exécutions
de l'ondam combo qu'on observe depuis
ces dernières années
je me permets de noter néanmoins que on
parle d'une dune d'une dépense qui fait
plus de 180 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui qui est essentiellement une
dépense entre guillemets de guichet un
d'activité suite à lierre ou de
remboursements de soins qui quand même
éminemment difficiles à prévoir quand
nous construisons les lois de
financement à l'automne et donc c'est
vrai que les ministres ont clairement
indiqué que le respect de l'ondam était
aujourd'hui un un élément structurant
nos politiques des finances publiques et
que de ce point de vue là il nous est
impératif de prendre quelques marches de
précaution ce qui explique la sous
consommation mais qui doit être heureux
la vie relativiser au regard des 180
milliards que j'évoquais nous faisons
des exercices de entre guillemets de
sais pas comment on va les appeler de
rétro collation en tout cas de regarder
de comparer l'évolution réelle par
rapport à nos économies escomptées par
rapport aux tendancielle j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que ne surestimons
pas les trajectoires dans l'ancien mais
même si l'exercice est difficile
certains postes typiquement comme des
arrêts de travail qui représente
si on regarde tous les toulousains
travail produit milliards d'euros sont
évidemment difficiles à prévoir sur le
lien avec la conjoncture économique est
fort mais
je crois que les travaux qui sont faits
sont relativement fiables ils sont je
crois assez transparent au regard des
annexes du plfss
mais voilà c'est des choses sur lequel
nous nous mettons à jour tous les ans
nos hypothèses sont anciennes la
question n'était pas tout à fait
pertinente à son récent à vous elle
était plus générale et je pensais pas
spécialement l'ondam ans et plus
généralement les trajectoires qui sont
définies pour les finances publiques
spécialement je ne visais pas
spécialement après ce que je peux
évoquer c'est que ces trajectoires jeu
au jour d'aujourd'hui sont sont sous le
sous l'oeil vigilant du haut conseil des
finances publiques qui est amenée
maintenant depuis l'année dernière
émettre un jugement à la fois sur les
hypothèses macroéconomiques et sur nos
trajectoire des finances publiques et
donc participent du monitoring global de
ces trajectoires bien mes chers
collègues donc le reste à remercier
monsieur directeur pour sa présentation
et sa réponse aussi claire que possible
à nos questions merci voilà pour
l'audition de thomas fatum le directeur
de la sécurité sociale qui a été
auditionnée par la mission commune
d'information sénatoriale sur l'impact
sur l'emploi des allègements de charges
sociales pour les entreprises
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 16h30 pour
24 heures sénat présenté par delphine
girard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
en